lisa feldman barrett
i know i'm not sure if you've done work
together but at least you're okay i
found out about her because of you
your podcast with her and then i brought
her onto instagram doing an instagram
live about emotion
and it was fascinating and she she's a
very spirited and very very smart
woman and uh fearless yeah and uh
brilliant so
i love her she's amazing uh she kind of
sh she's not a scholar of hallucigens
hallucinogens or dreams
but she had this intuition that there
may be a connection
between the kind of dissociation that
happens in dreaming
and that that happens in um like
psychedelics
i because of my previous conversation
with you
uh on on this podcast uh matthew johnson
from
johns hopkins reached out and he said
but
he he commented i think on something
that we competed i don't even remember
exactly what but that there's not
many studies it's not being uh
psychedelics and not being rigorously
studied
in an academic setting like with the
full rigor of science
and he said well actually uh that's
exactly what we're doing and they're
extremely well funded now and it was
been a long battle to get it accepted as
a serious
uh scientific pursuit so um
but and i'd like to ask you a little bit
about that but
do you have a sense about
connection between dreams and
psychedelics or these uh
different explorations of mind studies
that are outside of the standard normal
one that's
the wake mindset yeah i loved your
discussion with matthew i
knew of the hopkins group and the stuff
they were doing but i didn't know
much about it at all and i learned a ton
from that podcast i reached out to him
just to say i love what you're doing i
think it's incredible so yeah your
podcast has been
a great source of serious academic and
intellectual
um conversation for me i think what
they're doing at hopkins
is amazing he has a collaborator there
actually they had a very popular paper i
just throw out there for fun
um who was a postdoc at stanford her
name is ghoul
um she's turkish i believe um and
her and i i apologize her last name
escapes me at the moment but that's just
a function of my brain um
she had a paper showing that uh she put
octopi
on mdma on ecstasy and found out this
was published in
in a in current biology showing it was a
great journal showing that the octopi
then
wanted to spend more time with other
octopi they started cuddling
so their colleagues out there but um the
hopkins project is super interesting
because
i think they were initially supported
mainly through private philanthropy
and now you're starting to see some more
interest at the level of nih
about psychedelics it's a complicated
space because
the psychedelics are always looked at
through the lens of the 60s and people
losing their mind and
there's a you know in i always say you
know you don't want to ken keezy out of
the game you know ken kizu was amazing
right part of the whole beat generation
thing and he was actually at the va
near stanford that's where he eventually
in menlo park he wrote one flew over the
cuckoo's nest or
maybe that was about him anyway the
comments will tell me how wrong i am
but it's i think i'm tossing these words
in the general in the right general
direction
but you know huxley
keezy they did a lot of lsd and they
all lost their jobs right they lost
their jobs at big institutions like
harvard and stanford and elsewhere or
they left
um because they they made themselves the
experiments
yes hopkins as far as i know is when the
first place is
not the first place where whatever may
or may not be doing in his own life i
don't know
it's really about the patience and
whether or not the patients in these
institutional review board approve
studies whether or not they're getting
better
in situations like depression i think
it's clear that there's a very close
relationship
between hallucinogenic states and
dreaming of the sort that would describe
for rem dreaming
and there's a terrific set of books and
body of scientific literature from a guy
named alan hobson
who was an md is it harvard med and he
wrote books like dream drugstore
um one of the first neuroscience books i
ever read was about hallucinations and
how
psychedelics and dreaming are very
similar that was way back when i was in
high school i was just curious
and he really understood the
relationship between lsd and rem dreams
and how similar they are
i think psychedelics and matt knows way
more about this than i do of course but
psychedelics have some very interesting
properties
they are certainly not for everybody
right and kids it's a problem you know
i think the major issues right now
around the psychedelic
conversation is that it's clear that
they can unveil
certain elements of neuroplasticity they
make the brain amenable to change
changing up space-time relationships
changing up the emotional load of an
event and being able to reframe that
it's clear that happens but there's two
major issues
one is that people talk about plasticity
as if plasticity is the goal
but plasticity is a state within which
you can direct neurology and the
question is
what changes are you trying to get to so
people are just taking psychedelics
to unveil plasticity without thinking
about
what circuits they want to modify and
how i think that's a problem
i think there's great potential however
for people opening up these
states of plasticity with psychedelics
or otherwise and
directing the plastic changes toward a
particular endpoint and there's an
absolutely spectacular paper out of uc
davis
it publishes a full article in nature
just a couple months ago
showing that there are psychedelics that
are now can be modified so chemists have
gotten into the game now and modifying
to take away the hallucinogenic
component
where you still get the neural
plasticity components wow
and for a lot of people to be like oh
that's no fun that's not giving you the
the wild experience but i do think that
that holds great potential for people
that wouldn't otherwise
orient towards some of these drugs so i
think it's really marvelous what's
happening and what's about to happen
you